[Música]
Estados Unidos acaba de salir de un
ciclo electoral y ya está embarcado en
otro las elecciones del 5 de noviembre
de 2024 ya están en el radar y eso eso
significa una cosa las primarias de los
partidos para escoger a sus candidatos
están a punto de caramelo y por ahora el
partido republicano parece que tendrá
las primarias más disputadas
Durante los últimos años el expresidente
Trump además de acumular una enorme
colección de acusaciones judiciales y
derrotas electorales también ha dividido
y radicalizado al partido republicano
hoy es fácil encontrar a partidarios
suyos que niegan que Estados Unidos sea
una democracia que cuestiona la
legitimidad de los tribunales los
fiscales y el propio sistema electoral
hablamos en muchos casos de Auténticos
forofos que han encontrado en trampa su
particular Mesías
y por eso cada vez son más los
republicanos que creen que ha llegado la
hora de pasar página apostar por un
nuevo liderazgo y volver a los
principios y las posiciones que hasta la
llegada de Trump les definía incluido el
sentido de estado el compromiso con la
verdad y sí el respeto por el
contrincante político
[Música]
Wow Qué lejos parece ese tiempo
ahora bien Todavía no está claro que lo
vayan a conseguir porque Trump si Trump
se vuelve a presentar como candidato y
no solo eso a pesar de sus escándalos
sexuales como el de la antigua actriz
porno stormy Daniels del asalto al
Capitolio y la aparición de numerosos
documentos clasificados en su casa Trump
se ha vuelto a colocar en lo más alto de
la carrera republicana nunca me marcharé
Trump promete permanecer en la carrera
presidencial de 2024 Incluso si es
condenado podría transforzar a los
republicanos a tener un candidato a
presidente procesado por un delito
federal o incluso condenado y tal vez
encarcelado pues según muchos expertos
en leyes estadounidenses por poder
podría hacerlo por ahora no hay ningún
impedimento legal para presentarse a las
elecciones presidenciales incluso Aunque
terminase entre rejas es más ya hay dos
procedentes de algo así en 1920
debs líder del partido socialista
presentó su candidatura desde prisión y
en 1992 hizo lo propio lindon la Rush un
teórico de la conspiración que había
sido condenado por fraude en 1988 ahora
viene un momento porque este vídeo no va
del ex presidente Trump no al menos
directamente
Por eso tenemos que hacernos unas
cuantas preguntas es Trump imparable lo
veremos está el partido republicano
condenado a no pasar página difícilmente
tarde o temprano lo hará no hay acaso
otras figuras capaces de luchar por la
candidatura republicana Pues sí las hay
De hecho son ya varios los políticos que
han anunciado su candidatura a las
primarias republicanas entre ellos
tenemos al senador por Carolina del Sur
Team Scott al propio vicepresidente de
Trump Mike pence a la exgobernadora de
Carolina del Sur y antigua embajadora
ante la ONU Nicky Haley o alexgobernador
de Nueva Jersey y antiguo Aliado de
Trump Chris Christi entre otros pero si
hay un candidato que se ha presentado
Pisando fuerte con fama apoyos
importantes y mucho muchísimo dinero ese
no es otro que el actual gobernador de
Florida ron de santis
seguro que todos habéis oído hablar de
este político que consiguió barrer en
las últimas elecciones en el estado de
Florida un hombre que ha conseguido
transformar un estado históricamente
bisagra es decir disputado a cara de
perro por demócratas y republicanos a
uno fuertemente republicano por ejemplo
hace tan solo 5 años en 2018 de santis
ganó las elecciones a gobernador por
apenas
32.500 votos un margen del 0,4% y en
2022 qué pasó en 2022 Pues de santis
ganó con un margen de atención 19 puntos
ahora bien Qué ha hecho este tipo que
parece tan serio para levantar pasiones
en el estado del sol sería capaz de
Reproducir este increíble éxito a nivel
Federal si finalmente fuese el candidato
republicano a la casa blanca Pues bien
en este vídeo queridos amigos amigas os
vamos a contar todas las claves sobre
este peso pesado de la política
estadounidense os contaremos Cuáles han
sido sus principales hitos En Florida
qué visión tiene para el país y también
os contaremos por qué tiene serias
papeletas para terminar siendo un duro
contrincante para los demócratas Por
cierto en nuestra newsletter not news os
iremos compartiendo los datos y los
hitos claves de la campaña Empezando por
una radiografía de los candidatos que os
enviaremos en los próximos días un
momento que todavía no está suscrito a
not news.com A qué estás esperando
todavía estamos calentando motores Pero
podemos decir que ya somos miles de
amigos allí y os prometemos ir mejorando
mes tras mes es 100% gratuito y estamos
preparando muchas sorpresas Y si ya
estáis suscritos os gusta lo que hacemos
y queréis apoyarnos para que sigamos
mejorando no dudéis en echarle un
vistazo a nuestra comunidad de patreon y
aprovecho ya para daros un millón de
gracias a todos los que nos acompañáis
allí y ahora sí arranquemos con ron de
santis la promesa estrella o estrellada
del gop adelante
el éxito de ron
conservadurismo a la antigua usanza
mezclado con toques de tipo duro algo de
carisma un poco de populismo por aquí
por allá y formas y discursos bastante
polémicos ese sería el mejunje que
podría describir a the santis en una
sola frase pero evidentemente no no nos
vamos a quedar solamente en eso este
gobernador ha dado mucho de qué hablar y
el motivo lo tenemos en Florida el
estado de moda del que es gobernador
en los últimos años Florida está
viviendo un intenso despegue económico
con tasas de crecimiento superiores a
las del resto del país y una tasa de
desempleo prácticamente mínimos
históricos del 2,5%, algo que además
está impulsando la competencia de las
empresas por Buscar trabajadores lo que
está haciendo crecer los salarios en un
estado con salarios tradicionalmente
Bajos en el contexto norteamericano
con todos estos datos seguro que no se
extrañará saber que Florida fue en 2022
el estado que más población ganó de todo
el país con un crecimiento anual de casi
el 2%. además Bonaparte de esta
población no vino del extranjero sino de
otros estados Como por ejemplo Nueva
York o Illinois dos estados que junto a
California se han convertido en tres
colosos los tres demócratas Por cierto
que no paran de perder población
El caso es que por todos estos motivos
la la principal carta de presentación de
ron de santis de Cara a las primarias
republicanas es precisamente presentarse
con experiencia de gestión y hechos
éxitos que hablen por él y no solo
palabras vacías y ojo que no solo
hablamos de estadísticas también como
veremos de muchos cambios legislativos
muy importantes para los conservadores
pero ahora bien exactamente qué es lo
que ha hecho ron de santis y lo que es
más importante realmente es oro todo lo
que reluce Pues bien ya os adelanto que
en esta historia hay para todos los
gustos hay cal y hay arena a partes
iguales digamos que mientras que el
fuerte desempeño económico de Florida es
algo innegable la trayectoria de este
gobernador ahora precandidato está
repleta de políticas que a unos os
gustarán y a otros o se horrorizarán en
cualquier caso palabra que nos dejarán
indiferentes vamos con ellas
el hombre de hierro del paraíso
es un político que en materia social
recuerde mucho al republicanismo
conservador más tradicional Y sí en
Florida no ha escatimado en esfuerzos
para hacer virar las políticas las leyes
y las regulaciones del Estado hacía
posiciones más conservadoras O como le
gusta decir a él anti en español no
tiene una traducción exacta Pero sería
algo así como antiprogre we
haven't Pues bien de santis ha
conseguido convertirse en una de las
figuras más relevantes de la corriente
antigua en Estados Unidos
[Música]
por un lado podríamos empezar
mencionando su impulso a una ley que
prohíbe que las universidades puedan
emplear dinero Federal o Estatal para
desarrollar actividades que promocionen
la diversidad la igualdad y la inclusión
de santis quiere sacar del sistema
educativo debates que considera han sido
impuestos por la izquierda esta misma
ley también obliga a las universidades a
revisar sus planes de estudio para que
los temarios no distorsionen eventos
históricos ni incluían teorías críticas
basadas en la raza con esto se pretende
por ejemplo sacar de las aulas las
teorías que defienden que la población
afroamericana sigue sufriendo una
situación de discriminación o racismo
institucionalizado recordáis el Black
Life matters Pues eso
[Música]
Pero esto no es más que el principio
otra de las leyes más polémicas del
gobernador de Florida ha sido la ley de
derechos de los padres en la educación
más conocida popularmente como la ley no
digas gay
esta ley básicamente lo que hace es
prohibir o mejor dicho retrasar la
educación sexual incluido todo aquello
que tenga que ver con la diversidad
sexual en las escuelas públicas en un
principio la ley prohibía este tipo de
formación hasta que los estudiantes
tuvieran entre 8 y 9 años de edad pero
se acaba de emplear hasta que tengan 13
y 14 años por supuesto para sus
detractores esta ley sirve para
discriminar a los estudiantes y las
familias lgtb y también para prohibir
libros o películas en los Colegios que
aborden estas temáticas sin embargo para
sus Defensores esta ley tan solo hace
que sean los padres los que elijan el
momento y la forma en la que educan a
sus hijos en esta materia en lugar de
hacerlo el estado al menos hasta que
tengan una edad determinada sin duda
esta ha sido una de las leyes más
polémicas del gobierno de The santis en
Florida una ley que le ha costado un
enfrentamiento salvaje a cara de perro
con la mayor empresa del estado Disney
tras las protestas el ceo de Disney
habla en contra de la ley no digas gay
de Florida ahora bien porque es esto tan
importante Pues bien pensando un momento
Qué hay en la ciudad de Orlando que le
gustaría visitar a todos los niños del
mundo Exacto el complejo temático Disney
World
Pues bien El caso es que precisamente
por tener tanta presencia en este estado
Disney empezó a recibir fuertes
presiones por parte de activistas para
que se posicionaran en contra de esta
ley y bueno cuando finalmente lo
hicieron digamos que de santis perdió
los papeles y empezó a comportarse
prácticamente como un Caudillo Bananero
sí amigos este es quizás uno de sus
mayores borrones en el historial
arremeter contra la mayor empresa del
estado y amenazarla con cambios y
castigos legales por ejercer su derecho
a expresarse como les dé la gana No sé
no suena muy bien mal ahí gobernador el
gobernador de Florida ron de santis
firma una ley para poner el distrito de
Disney bajo el control estatal en este
vídeo no vamos a entrar en esto de los
distritos gestionados por empresas de
eso hablaremos en otra ocasión Pero lo
que sí creo que tenemos que tener en
cuenta es que un político no debería
usar su poder para castigar política y
fiscalmente a empresas que se expresen
en su contra el estado que gobiernan no
es su Cortijo personal pero al Señor de
santis le dio un poco igual de hecho se
suele comparar con Teddy Roosevelt a la
hora de lanzar su particular Cruzada
contra las grandes corporaciones porque
sí ron de santis tiene a las grandes
corporaciones en su Diana ahora bien si
creéis que eso es todo Esta es muy
equivocados de Santi se ha dado mucho
más de Sí en sus más de cuatro años como
gobernador de Florida
este gobernador también impulsado leyes
para prohibir que las agencias estatales
tengan en cuenta Los criterios sg esto
es Los criterios ambientales sociales y
de gobernanza a la hora de invertir
recientemente también ha prohibido el
aborto a partir de las seis semanas de
embarazo en lugar de las 15 semanas que
el propio de santis se estableció en
2022 lo que para los críticos equivale a
prohibir una gran parte de los abortos
porque un tercio de las mujeres se
enteran de que están embarazadas después
de las 6 semanas y un 20% lo hace
incluso más tarde
[Música]
ya veis que todo tiene un patrón común
de santis va de frente y a toda
velocidad contra consignas que han
dominado Durante los últimos años el
discurso político a su lado Donald Trump
es prácticamente un aprendiz entre otras
cosas por una cuestión de convicción ron
de santis sí cree realmente en todos
estos cambios y siguiendo esta
particular agenda conservadora Made In
América que nos falta Exacto otra de las
medidas relevantes de desantis en
Florida ha sido flexibilizar mucho el
uso y porte de armas de fuego
concretamente ha promovido una ley que
permite a cualquier persona en la
Florida poseer armas y llevarlas ocultas
por la calle sin necesidad de tener
ninguna licencia ni comprobación de
antecedentes ni nada de nada para de
santis está claro portar armas es un
derecho constitucional así Bueno también
Y esta es otra de las medidas polémicas
del gobernador de Florida ha facilitado
la pena de muerte eliminando la
unanimidad de los 12 miembros del Jurado
Que hasta ahora la ley exigía por una
súper mayoría de 8 frente a cuatro
menuda agenda y todavía no Hemos llegado
al tema de la inmigración
de Santi se ha convertido en una de las
figuras políticas más duras de Estados
Unidos contra la inmigración ilegal
podemos decir que en Florida su gobierno
le ha declarado la guerra a los
inmigrantes indocumentados y ojo porque
esto es importante saberlo en Estados
Unidos un inmigrante ilegal a día de hoy
en la práctica puede trabajar puede
tener carnet de conducir e incluso puede
comprarse una casa o escolarizar a sus
hijos en este sentido es un país mucho
menos estricto que por ejemplo la norma
habitual en Europa o muchos países
asiáticos siempre que vayas a trabajar y
cumplas las normas y las leyes a
rajatabla digamos que es un país en el
que se hace mucho la vista gorda con eso
de tener o no documentación ahora bien
parece que ha de santis no lo hace
demasiada gracia este sistema y por eso
le ha declarado la guerra en Florida
el gobernador del estado del sol ha
tomado toda una serie de medidas Como
por ejemplo tipificar como delito grave
de tercer grado utilizar un carnet falso
para conseguir un empleo también ha
prohibido que los inmigrantes ilegales
puedan conducir incluso los casos en los
que porten un carnet de otro estado que
no sea Florida y no solo eso los
empleadores privados con 25 o más
trabajadores tendrán que usar un sistema
de verificación electrónica de forma
obligatoria para confirmar que los
trabajadores están legalmente en Florida
y además obligará a los hospitales que
estén adscritos al programa Medicaid a
preguntar por el estatus legal de los
pacientes Todas estas son medidas
diseñadas para facilitar la
identificación de los inmigrantes
ilegales
[Música]
sorprendidos amigos este tipo deja Trump
casi como un progre migración a su lado
pero es que es más todas estas medidas
han ido acompañadas de todo un show
mediático bastante cuestionable cuál
Pues fijaos en floridano de santis manda
decenas de inmigrantes ilegales a
martha's intensificando la táctica
contra los destinos santuarios
ahora bien Qué es eso de los destinos
santuario Y por qué dedicar expresamente
12 millones de dólares a mandar a
decenas de inmigrantes a una isla del
estado de Nueva York situada a más de
1600 kilómetros de la Florida Pues bien
se trata Ni más ni menos que de una
campaña de marketing político a nivel
nacional y la elección del destino no es
ni mucho menos accidental
Y es que veréis según las leyes del
estado de Nueva York las autoridades
tienen que hacerse cargo inicialmente de
los inmigrantes ilegales que llegan al
estado por ejemplo otorgándoles
alojamiento sin embargo últimamente este
sistema ha colapsado debido a las
llegadas masivas lo que ha hecho que
muchos inmigrantes tengan que ser
alojados en hoteles algo que ha
disparado el gasto del estado y de la
propia ciudad de Nueva York
Pues bien la medida de The santis parece
querer atacar la línea de flotación de
los estados y ciudades santuario esto es
territorios que limitan su cooperación
con el Gobierno Federal en cuestiones de
control migratorio y que él considera
que promueven el efecto llamada de
inmigrantes ilegales inmigrantes que
según de santis en muchos casos entran
por Florida
ahora bien Por qué marxas vinger Pues
porque esta isla de Nueva York es el
destino favorito de vacaciones y segunda
residencias de un montón de millonarios
y políticos afines al partido demócrata
hasta el expresidente Barack Obama tiene
una casa de más de 12 millones de
dólares allí es decir que lo que de
santis buscaba era hacer que esas élites
demócratas vivieran el drama de la
inmigración ilegal en su propio Cortijo
vacacional eso al menos es lo que su
equipo ha dicho para justificar
semejante campaña que si lo pensáis bien
y estéis o no de acuerdo con ser más o
menos estrictos con la inmigración no
hace sino tratar a las personas como
auténtico ganado Y qué queréis que os
diga pagarse una campaña de publicidad
personal a nivel nacional a cargo de los
contribuyentes de Florida ahora bien
puede que llegados a este punto y ahora
que os hemos contado sus principales
hitos como gobernador seguramente
tengáis más o menos claro el tipo de
político el perfil con el que nos
encontramos Pero qué hay de sus
propuestas para el conjunto del país qué
haría si fuera presidente y qué
posiciones tendría sobre los asuntos más
importantes a nivel internacional Pues
bien no esperemos más descubramoslo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
make América Florida
amigos amigas de visualpolitik como
seguramente ya os habréis imaginado por
el título de este bloque la agenda
política de ron de santis para Estados
Unidos se basa en una cosa hacer América
a imagen y semejanza de su Florida la
Florida que la ha estado cambiando
Durante los últimos cuatro años por
tanto las líneas principales de la
política de The santis podrían pasar por
extender Al conjunto del país todas o la
mayoría de las leyes que os hemos
contado hace un momento y Eso incluye el
extender y facilitar la pena de muerte
restringir la educación sexual hasta
bien entrada a la adolescencia la guerra
frontal contra la inmigración ilegal o
la lucha contra las grandes empresas que
no le bailen el agua ahora bien la
política a nivel Federal es distinta que
la estatal en muchas cosas por ejemplo
porque desde la casa blanca de santis
tendría que marcar una agenda
internacional y aquí aquí es donde nos
asaltan nuevas dudas de qué forma ve de
santis el mundo Qué se puede esperar de
posicionamientos internacionales Pues
bien para saberlo lo primero que debemos
hacer es mirar a Ucrania en el partido
republicano la división actual es tan
grande que hay un sector mayoritario que
es fuertemente procrania y otanista y a
la vez otro sector fuertemente prorruso
que exige el fin de la ayuda
estadounidense aquí y en medio bueno
quizás en un término medio es donde se
encuentra actualmente de santis
2015 cuando era congresista y justo
después de la ocupación rusa de crimea
de santis fue uno de los grandes
impulsores de la ayuda militar americana
Ucrania ahora en cambio su posición ha
cambiado y pasaba porque esta ayuda no
es vital para los intereses nacionales
de Estados Unidos según él Estados
Unidos tiene que focalizarse los
problemas internos como la epidemia de
opioides o la crisis migratoria la
cuestión es que estos problemas ya
existían en 2015 es decir que de santis
ha cambiado de discurso en un tema tan
importante Simplemente porque quiere
captar los votos trampistas algo por lo
que también ha puesto en duda la
imparcialidad y el objetivo político de
los juicios contra Donald Trump
[Música]
en
ensh that is When you know that has
beenses
[Aplausos]
pero volvamos al tema exterior
[Música]
No ayudar a los aliados en temas vitales
haría que el país se mostrase como un
socio poco fiable y sí no lo dudemos
esto podría volver a dar alas a los
regímenes totalitarios para actuar con
impunidad todos recordamos como la
inacción y la ambigüedad de Trump
terminó con china cargándose ilegalmente
el estatus político especial que tenía
Hong Kong sin embargo no tan rápido
porque la agenda internacional de The
santis puede tener muchas más
contradicciones que certidumbres por
ejemplo si no hablamos de Ucrania pero
hablamos de Taiwán de santis dice que es
un país de interés crítico para Estados
Unidos y se ha posicionado a favor de
seguir supliéndoles armas además también
como gobernador ha sido muy beligerante
con china llegando a prohibir a casi
todos los ciudadanos chinos invertir en
inmuebles en Florida
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Y no sólo eso también es un fuerte
defensor de Israel y de la asistencia
americana al país hebreo suscribe Los
acuerdos de Abraham y por supuesto
defiende que la embajada estadounidense
está en Jerusalén en el terreno
latinoamericano de Santi se opone a
relajar las sanciones contra Cuba y es
muy crítico con el régimen de maduro
Claro que cuando se trata de ayudar a
los inmigrantes la cosa cambia Porque
muchos de los inmigrantes que de santis
ha expulsado en aviones de Florida y los
ha enviado a otros estados eran
precisamente gente que huía del régimen
chavista de Venezuela
en fin sabéis esto de no predicar con el
ejemplo pues eso des antes en resumidas
cuentas es un político que como decíamos
al principio del vídeo mezcla
conservadurismo en estado puro mano dura
carisma algo de populismo y un extraño
placer por actuar sin importarle
demasiado el qué dirán Claro que su
mensaje nos alerta de que es un político
capaz de dejar vendido a un país como
Ucrania frente a Putin quizás solo por
una mera cuestión electoral de cara al
llegar al 2024 llevándole la contraria a
la actual de la Casa Blanca Y de paso
regar las orejas al electorado trampista
recordemos que Trump siempre ha
mantenido que todo esto de la invasión
de Ucrania lo arreglaba con una llamada
en cosa de 24 horas Qué miedo
En definitiva hablamos de un perfil
lleno de contrastes contradicciones y
guiños a sectores radicales del Go que
ha hecho que muchos le vean como una
especie de trap con buenos modales
Aunque Honestamente si sois
conservadores Creo que este candidato os
gustará mucho más que Trump ahora bien
llegamos a este punto las preguntas son
para ti qué piensas del perfil político
de The santis piensas que logrará su
aparente objetivo de aunar el apoyo del
partido republicano más tradicional y el
de los trampistas logrará vencer a su
antaño amigo Y hoy no tan amigo Trump en
las primarias Pues bien déjanos tu
opinión aquí abajo en los comentarios y
recuerda si te ha gustado este vídeo No
olvides darle al botón de like y
suscribirte a nuestro canal Para no
perderte ninguna novedad Ah Y también
recuerda que puedes suscribirte a
nuestro patreon para recibir contenidos
y regalos exclusivos tenéis el enlace
abajo en la descripción una vez más
Muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]